[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
sind sie noch zu retten haben Kaufhäuser
überhaupt noch eine Zukunft die Frage
drängt sich auf wenn man sich den
erneuten Kahlschlag bei Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof ansieht zum Kaufhof gehen das
ist für viele Menschen eben längst
ersetzt worden durch bei Amazon
bestellen das ist aber wohl nicht der
einzige Grund dafür dass die letzte noch
verbliebene Warenhauskette nicht auf die
Beine kommt und jetzt weitere 52
Filialen schließen will ein Schock für
die Beschäftigten aber auch für die
Standorte wird das Folgen haben
leerstehende Kolosse machen Innenstädte
ja nicht gerade attraktiver Thaddäus
Parade berichtet
gehofft hatten sie bis zuletzt doch als
die Nachricht über das Ende von Galeria
Karstadt Kaufhof in Dortmund die Runde
macht ist die Enttäuschung in der
Belegschaft groß Anfang 2024 wird das
traditionswarenhaus in der Dortmunder
City Geschichte sein noch früher trifft
es Galeria Kaufhof in Neuss die Filiale
stand bereits vor zwei Jahren auf der
Streichliste nun ist beschlossen Ende
Juni ist endgültig Schluss
mit Kaufhof und gerade auch hier mit der
Filiale in Neuss verbinde ich eigentlich
Familie weil man verbringt die meiste
Zeit hier man hat die Kollegen man fängt
sich auf man tauscht sich aus und das
tut glaube ich mit am meisten weh dass
man diese Familie verliert es ist auch
ein Stück deutscher
Wirtschaftsgeschichte die dann aus
vielen Innenstädten verschwindet alles
unter einem Dach knapp 100 Jahre war das
ein Erfolgsmodell viele große Namen sind
bereits verschwunden nun ein weiterer
großer Aderlass bei Deutschlands letztem
großen Warenhauskonzern 52 Häuser werden
geschlossen teilt Chefs an ihre Hand
geiles mit
das ist zweifellos heute für uns alle
ein schwerer Tag wir haben in den
vergangenen Wochen intensiv um jeden
einzelnen Standort gerungen die
verbleibenden Filialen haben eine
tragfähige wirtschaftliche Perspektive
mit einem Sortiment das stärker auf
regionale Bedürfnisse ausgerichtet ist
sollen die Häuser in die Zukunft geführt
werden doch gibt es die überhaupt noch
das Warenhaus hat sich schon vor 40
Jahren überlebt dass läuft aus es ist
quasi in Dinosaurier der am Sterben ist
und jemand vielleicht noch durch eine
Spritze für ein paar Tage wiederbeleben
kann aber der hat keine Zukunft die
Statistik jedenfalls heißt nichts Gutes
seit 2019 hat sich die Zahl der Filialen
mehr als halbiert trotz üppiger
Staatshilfen in Höhe von 680 Millionen
Euro kritik gab es deswegen auch immer
wieder am österreichischen
immobilienmilliardär und Eigner Rene
Benko ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
es Herrn Benko um das operative Geschäft
gegangen ist weil dann hätte er mehr
Geld in Galeria eingeschossen ich glaube
die Strategie von den Wenko ist schlicht
und ergreifend noch reicher zu werden
und zwar mit Immobilien am
Warenhausgeschäft kann er nicht
interessiert sein denn der Umsatz hat
sich seit seiner Übernahme gedrittelt
nun stehen Städte wie Neuss vor einem
riesen Problem wuchtige Betonarchitektur
aus den 70er Jahren in aller bester Lage
und demnächst leer
große Stichwort das heißt wir müssen
schauen dass wir innerhalb eines
Gebäudes auch verschiedene Funktionen
einer Stadt mit bedienen und das ist
nicht mehr Handel allein ohne Handel
wird es auch nicht gehen das ist
sicherlich klar aber Handel allein wird
es nicht mehr richten sondern müssen uns
die Frage stellen welche weiteren
Funktionen können wir in den Immobilien
abbilden in Recklinghausen hat man
diesen Schritt schon fast vollzogen dort
steht vom alten Karstadt Gebäude nur
noch die Fassade im Innern gibt es ein
Hotel ein Altenheim Gastronomie und auf
dem Dach demnächst auch eine Kita
fragen wir noch mal nach bei unserem
Wirtschaftsexperten Frank bedmann Frank
das klingt unterm Strich schon ein
bisschen so als wäre die Ära der
Warenhäuser ja eigentlich endgültig
vorbei nee ich will es mal so sagen es
ist ziemlich sicher einer der letzten
Versuche Galeria Karstadt Kaufhof zu
retten die Kette sucht ja bereits seit
Jahren nach Antworten auf das veränderte
Einkaufsverhalten der Menschen bislang
ohne wirklichen Erfolg jetzt also will
man das Sortiment stärker auf regionale
Bedürfnisse ausrichten online und
Filiale besser verzahnen und die Häuser
zu Treffpunkten in den Innenstädten
weiterentwickeln mit zum Beispiel einem
besseren Gastronomieangebot
ja da gibt es ja so einiges was im
Gespräch ist wie erfolgversprechend sind
denn diese Lösungsansätze die da
diskutiert werden ja die Ideen die man
hat sind gut es hängt ein bisschen von
der Umsetzung ab man will sich
dezentraler aufstellen die
Konzernzentrale soll nicht mehr alles
entscheiden erstes Problem der Einkauf
man sagte immer so schön der Erfolg
liegt im Einkauf je mehr man kauft desto
besser die Preise macht man es
regionaler werden die Mengen kleiner und
die waren dann eher teurer und dann
dieses dezentrale Modell mit einer
Logistik verknüpfen die auch online mit
einbezieht ist alles andere als trivial
ein Beispiel der Kunde sucht sich ein
Kleidungsstück im Kaufhaus aus das ist
leider in der passenden Größe nicht mehr
da online schauen wo ist der Artikel
noch vorhanden in welchem Lager und dann
noch möglichst am nächsten Tag dem
Kunden nach Hause liefern das muss die
schöne neue Einkaufswelt sein um so eine
Infrastruktur aber aufzubauen muss man
investieren genauso wie in die weitere
Modernisierung der
mitten rein in die Show in der Moderator
Jimmy Kimme historisches zu bieten hatte
denn zwei hatten gleich zu Beginn gut
lachen und Jamie Lee Curtis beide noch
nie für einen Oscar nominiert jetzt
bekamen sie ihn für ihre Nebenrollen in
dem verrückten Werk everything
everywhere all at once
gut aus eine depressive
waschsalon-besitzerin auf wilder Jagd
durch parallele Universen
Crunch spielte einstalskind im Indiana
Jones Film für seinen späten Erfolg
jetzt dankte er seiner 84-jährigen
Mutter
noch historischer im Doppelsinn wohl das
bester internationaler Film für im
Westen
blinder Patriotismus und sinnloses
Morden brutal in Bild und tot vier
Oscars bekam das Team für seine erste
weltkriegs-epos
Regisseur bedankte sich besonders bei
seinem Hauptdarsteller Felix Kamera in
seinem allerersten Kinofilm
es gab einige Überraschungen
Natur aus dem indischen Film AAA
ausgezeichnet als bester Song
und Brandon Fraser als bester
Hauptdarsteller eigentlich galt seine
Karriere als beendet als vereinsamter
Mann mit immensen Übergewicht nun ein
grandioses Comeback
ist gestorben und das hat mir zu
schaffen
dann die Botschaft des Abends von der
ersten asiatischstämmigen Gewinnerin als
beste Schauspielerin Michael
Ladies Ladies lasst euch von niemandem
je sagen ihr hättet das beste hinter
euch
mit insgesamt sieben Oskars auch als
bester Film ist everything everywhere
all at once der große Sieger dieses
Abends kein Problem für das im Westen
nichts Neues Team sie freuen sich über
den größten Erfolg der Geschichte für
das deutsche Kino
historisch ist unvergesslich das hat
noch nicht gegeben ich glaube da werden
wir alle noch ein Weilchen brauchen das
zu verdauen damit jetzt hier in
Hollywood wieder anzukommen wo 1929 die
erste Verfilmung gemacht wurde als der
Film damals in Deutschland schon nicht
mehr gemacht werden konnte jetzt wieder
herzukommen und so gewürdig zu werden
ist ein großes Glück und das Feiern sie
dann noch ausgiebig
dann sende ich jetzt erstmal einen
herzlichen Glückwunsch nach Los Angeles
zu etwas ärgern guten Tag Herr Berger
herzlichen Dank guten Tag haben sie
eigentlich überhaupt schon geschlafen
oder bis jetzt durch gefeiert
ich habe sehr wenig geschlafen ich habe
die Sonne aufgesehen und bin dann ins
Bett gegangen
sie haben wir die Hoffnung geäußert dass
dieser dieser Preis diese Preise ist
sind ja gleich viel Oscars dem deutschen
Film auch einen Aufschub geben könnte
naja das ist schon eine große
Verantwortung ich weiß nicht ob wir die
alleine schultern können aber natürlich
hat Filme machen beim Fußball hört man
das ja immer wieder ja wenn Spieler
Selbstvertrauen brauchen vom Trainer
oder vom Publikum oder ausgebucht werden
oder angejubelt werden dann spielen die
auch anders und so geht uns auch und so
geht's uns auch im Grunde ja man braucht
ja auch ein Selbstvertrauen und ein
Vertrauen
der anderen und Vertrauen in sich selbst
dass man irgendwie den nächsten Film gut
machen kann und da ist es ist es glaube
ich ganz wichtig und dafür kann es mir
zumindest glaube ich helfen und ich
hoffe auch und wenn sich ein paar andere
davon anstecken lassen dann freue ich
mich natürlich
dann ist dieser Film gedreht worden in
einer Zeit in der sie nicht an konnte
dass die Realität quasi diesen Film
einholt also dass dieses Historien Epos
dass sie auf die Leinwand bringen nun
überlagert wird regelrecht oder parallel
steht zu den realen Bildern die denen
des Films zu erschreckend mit dem
Ukraine Krieg mit diesen schlammigen
Schützengräben man hat das Gefühl man
sieht Film und Realität nicht zugleich
wie geht ihnen das wie empfinden Sie das
ja ich glaube das ist am Ende haben wir
nur einen Film gemacht ja das ist
natürlich weit von der Realität der
Aktualität in der Ukraine entfernt und
es ist wie gesagt nur ein Film wir haben
versucht einen Film über unsere
Vergangenheit zu machen
die ja sehr geschichtsträchtig ist und
auch viel Verantwortung mit sich bringt
und darüber wollten wir erzählen und das
in die Welt tragen und plötzlich als der
Film fertig war
wurde er zum Film auch über die
Gegenwart und das hat uns natürlich
erschrocken und man kann eigentlich nur
hoffen dass Texte wie von remark
geschrieben irgendwann helfen uns in der
Zukunft die Fehler zu vermeiden die wir
immer wieder begeben ja aber am Ende ist
es wie gesagt nur ein Film und ich bin
auch kein Politiker und bin auch ein
Stecker und nicht in der Haut der
Ukraine kann nur einfach
in viel Kraft drin und meine
Unterstützung schicken
aber das ist natürlich viel tragischer
dort als das was wir alles darstellen
können
aus solchen Büchern und Filmen
anscheinend nicht lernt und sich
Geschichte wiederholt und ja sogar diese
Art von Stellungskriegen wiederholen die
sie in ihrem Film so so deutlich
darstellen wenn Sie heute das dieses
Drehbuch noch mal auf den Tisch bekommen
würden würden sie dann zögern und sagen
oh ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt so einen
Stoff gerade jetzt verarbeiten will oder
würden Sie sagen doch jetzt erst recht
ich würde wahrscheinlich erstmal hoffen
dass der Krieg so schnell wie möglich
vorüber ist und mich dann diesem Thema
widmen weil man möchte sich auch nicht
damit ein auseinander sind zumindest
fiktiv nicht auseinander im Grunde
stellen wir ja Dinge nach ja die sind
nicht real und ich würde mir dabei
komisch vorkommen etwas nachzustellen
mit Statisten und Schauspielern zu tun
als ob wenn es wirklich irgendwo anders
in der Nähe von uns passiert weil
irgendwo gibt es immer Krieg auf der
Welt es gibt auch übrigens in Syrien ja
auch noch einen Krieg wie wir alle
wissen über den sprechen wir gerade
nicht aber in unserer Nähe in einer
direkten Nachbarschaft hat es vielleicht
momentan noch mal eine ganz andere
Wirkung auf uns und auf uns auch
psychologisch dann haben sie mal gesagt
und es macht einen Unterschied ob man
als Deutscher einen Kriegsfilm oder Anti
Kriegsfilm macht oder ob Amerikaner oder
Briten das tun weil wir eigentlich nicht
die Möglichkeit haben deutsche Soldaten
in jedenfalls in einem historischen
Stoff als Helden darzustellen hat das zu
dem besonderen Erfolg in der Film gerade
in den USA und den UK also in
Großbritannien hatte beigetragen
diese andere Angaben
dass das kann sein zumindest hat die
Leute da immer wieder immer wieder ein
Gesprächen habe ich gemerkt dass sie
sagten Mensch darüber habe ich noch nie
nachgedacht aber das war natürlich der
große Grund für uns diesen Film zu
machen es gibt ja das Buch schon was
eine riesenhürde ist das noch mal zu
verfilmen es gibt einen ein großartigen
Film der auch die Geschichte überdauert
hat das noch mal eine höher ist also die
doppelte Hürde die man da überspringen
will oder oder muss oder diese diese
diese Gedanken aufbringen muss um das zu
machen und das ist nicht so ganz einfach
da ja sozusagen und
ich glaube aber das war der große Grund
für uns den Film zu machen weil wir
kennen viele die amerikanischen und
englischen Kriegsfilme und sie haben
natürlich immer diese Helden weil die
können diese Geschichte erzählen sie
England wurde angegriffen musste sich
verteidigen Amerika hat Europa vom
Faschismus im Zweiten Weltkrieg befreit
und im Ersten Weltkrieg sind sie
eingegriffen gegen ihren Willen und das
hinterlässt eine ganz andere
Vergangenheit ganz ganz andere
Geschichte eine Nachkommen auch in den
Nachkommen der Filme machen natürlich
machen die
andere Filme und die fühlen sich anders
an und die fühlen sich für uns
vielleicht auch manchmal befremdlich an
weil natürlich kann man dort auch mit
Ehre oder mit einem gewissen Stolz auf
diese Vergangenheit zurückblicken in
Deutschland geht das nicht und dann
musste ich der Film mal automatisch ganz
anders anfühlen und das fand ich
interessant mit anderen Ländern zu
teilen
und das ist auch anscheinend in England
oder in Amerika oder auch in Frankreich
und Spanien überall eigentlich
fruchtbaren Boden getroffen das freut
mich natürlich dass das so eine Art
Diskussion auslöst dass man eine
amerikanischen Film neben deutschen Film
setzen kann und dass das wie so eine Art
Dialog ergibt danke
für das Feiern sie noch schön
vielen Dank
die Bundeswehr bekommt einen neuen
generalinspektorin damit beginnen jetzt
bei dir die Nachrichten Heinz
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius wird
nach übereinstimmenden Berichten Karsten
Breuer mit dem Posten des ranghöchsten
Soldaten betrauen Breuer ist derzeit
Befehlshaber des neuen territorialen
führungskommandos der Bundeswehr zuvor
hatte der 58-Jährige den Corona
Krisenstab im Kanzleramt geleitet Breuer
folgt demnach auf den 63-Jährigen
general Eberhard Zorn
die Ukraine ist im Zuge des russischen
Angriffs Krieges schlagartig zu einem
der größten
rüstungsimporteure geworden laut dem
Forschungsinstitut siebrief gab es davor
kaum Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine im
Jahr 2022 sei die Ukraine dann zum
weltweit drittgrößten rüstungsimporär
geworden hinter Katar und Indien
das Militär und die Ausgaben dafür waren
auch ein Thema des chinesischen
Volkskongresses der heute zu Ende ging
die Delegierten billigsten mit dem neuen
Haushalt auch eine erhebliche Steigerung
der Militärausgaben um
7,2%. Präsident hi sagte in einer Rede
die Volksarmee müsste zu einer großen
stahlmauer ausgebaut werden die die
nationale Souveränität Sicherheit und
entwicklungsinteressen wirksam schützt
für die Wirtschaft wird nach dem Ende
der null-politik ein Wachstum von rund
5% als Ziel ausgegeben
und mit dem Volkskongress und
insbesondere auch mit der Haltung
Pekings in der taiwanfrage beschäftigt
sich später dann unser heute journal
Update
bei einem sogenannten krankenhausgipfel
haben Verbandsvertreter aus dem
Gesundheitswesen Experten und
Gesundheitspolitiker über die
Finanzsituation und eine klinikreform
diskutiert Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach Warp erneut für seine
Reformpläne ein zentrales Vorhaben ist
eine einheitliche Einteilung der
Kliniken in drei Stufen
wohnortnahe Kliniken zur Grund- und
Notfallversorgung Häuser mit Regel und
Schwerpunktversorgung also weiteren
Leistungen und Maximalversorger wie
Unikliniken
aus dem Südosten Afrikas werden immer
mehr Todesopfer durch einen
außergewöhnliche langanhaltenden
Tropensturm gemeldet am schlimmsten
betroffen ist der Süden Malawis allein
dort sind fast 100 Menschen umgekommen
der Sturm hatte am Freitag erneut Land
erreicht bereits zum zweiten Mal
innerhalb eines Monats
sind so viele Stühle zu viele Stühle
dass der Bundestag aus allen Nähten
platzt und dass da so auch nicht
weitergehen kann das aus den
vorgesehenen 598 sitzen inzwischen 736
geworden sind darüber sind sich
eigentlich alle einig nur jeder Versuch
den Problem beizukommen scheiterte daran
dass immer irgendjemand sich
benachteiligt fühlt keine Partei will
eine Reform zustimmen bei der sie sich
als Verliererin sieht das kann man auch
verstehen macht es aber natürlich schwer
eine Lösung zu finden die Ampelkoalition
hat jetzt Vorschläge für eine
Wahlrechtsreform vorgelegt durch die der
Bundestag wieder verkleinert wird sie
sollen noch diese Woche vom Bundestag
beschlossen werden aus der Opposition
gibt es allerdings heftigen Protest
Daniel Thompson erklärt die Hintergründe
zuletzt kam also immer mehr Stühle hinzu
nie saßen so viele Abgeordnete im
Bundestag wie diese Legislaturperiode
eben 736 bei eigentlich nur vorgesehenen
598 doch seit einer Wahlrechtsreform
2013 blähten Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate den Bundestag immer
stärker auf aktuell um 138 Mandate mit
dem neuen Entwurf soll die Zahl ab der
nächsten Wahl auf 630 Abgeordnete
festgeschrieben werden Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate sollen komplett
wegfallen
wir haben das zentrale Problem angepackt
und gelöst dass der Bundestag nämlich
absolut wechselnde Größen hat und sehr
schnell zu einem sehr großen Bundestag
werden kann zukünftig gilt bei jeder
Bundestagswahl der Bundestag hat 630
Abgeordnete das steht falsch der Entwurf
Gesetz wird einer der größten
Kritikpunkte diesmal das durch den
Wegfall der Überhangmandate manche
Wahlkreise keinen direkt gewählten
Abgeordneten mehr in den Bundestag
entsenden würden solche verweiste
Wahlkreise gäbe es weniger als bei einem
vorherigen Vorschlag aber einige gäbe es
nach wie vor betroffen wären laut
Entwurf die wahlkreisgewinne die mit der
niedrigsten Prozentzahl gewinnen also
auf da wurde demokratische Wettbewerb am
größten ist die Sorge dass dann in
Großstädten die Kandidaten hinten
rüberfallen und dafür in den
Sommerferien Regionen indem man notfalls
auch ein
Stock aufstellen könnte wenn er nur die
richtige verarbeite
ählt würde wenn die dann durchkommen
also das ist sicherlich Demokratie
theoretisch ganz misslich zudem soll
laut Ampel Entwurf die sogenannte
grundmandatsklausel gestrichen werden
bisher garantiert die das Parteien die
mindestens drei Wahlkreise gewinnen in
Fraktionsstärke in den Bundestag
einziehen selbst dann wenn sie unter der
5% Hürde bleiben genau dies ist aktuell
bei der Linken der Fall
dass sie das jetzt machen hat nur einen
Grund nämlich politisch die Linke
mittels des Wahlrechts platt zu machen
und das ist schon eine so große Sauerei
das hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten
es gelten für alle Parteien die gleichen
Regeln 5% muss man erringen im Deutschen
Bundestag mitzuspielen das sind die
gleichen Regeln die für alle gelten und
das jetzt das Ergebnis was als Ampel
erzählt haben zum
Ärger vor allem auch der CSU ihr
Stimmenanteil ist da sie nur in Bayern
Eintritt bundesweit entsprechend niedrig
zuletzt nur noch knapp über 5% bei einem
Absinken unter diesem Marke wäre auch
sie künftig komplett raus wir werden es
CSU die nicht zustimmen diese
veränderungswahlrecht wir werden wenn
sich nichts ändert auch eine Klage
dagegen einreichen dem sehen wir mit
großer Gelassenheit entgegen wir haben
uns beraten lassen von
Verfassungsrechtlern wir haben uns
unsere eigene Meinung gebildet und wir
sind davon überzeugt dass dieses
Wahlrecht weniger Risiken birgt als das
letzte Wahlrecht das von CDU und CSU
geschlossen wurde
Stimmen der Opposition braucht die Ampel
für ihre Reform nicht doch auch Ampel
intern gibt es manche kritische Stimme
kommt dennoch die benötigte einfache
Mehrheit zustande wäre dann also
voraussichtlich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht gefragt
[Musik]
das Banken Pleiten gefährlich sind war
eine leere die man aus der
Weltfinanzkrise 2018 konnte als damals
bei der Investmentbank Lehman Brothers
die Lichter ausgingen war noch nicht
jedem klar was das für Folgen haben
würde die Fernsehbilder von Angestellten
die ihre persönliche Habe in Pappkartons
aus dem New Yorker Hochhaus trugen
wirkten eher kurios die damalige
US-Regierung Griff zunächst nicht ein am
Ende war die ganze Welt betroffen wie
Dominosteine vielen finanzkonstrukte in
sich zusammen Bankenrettung und Bad
Banks wurden zu verhassten Schlagworten
insofern wird man natürlich schon
hellhörig wenn jetzt die Pleite der
Silicon Valley Bank Schlagzeilen macht
was ist damit auf sich hat berichtet
Benjamin Daniel
die kalifornische Sonne war noch nicht
aufgegangen als sich die ersten Kunden
vor diesem Silicon Valley Bankgebäude in
Santa Clara versammelten der
US-Präsident Versicherte das Anleger
trotz der Pleite an ihr Geld kommen
die Amerikaner können darauf vertrauen
dass das Bankensystem sicher ist ihre
Einlagen sind da wenn Sie sie brauchen
das Versicherten auch das
US-Finanzministerium die Notenbank sowie
die us-einlagensicherung FDIC die
Londoner Großbank HSBC dies heute die
Übernahme der britischen svb-tochter
verkünden Einlagen gesichert aufatmen
auch bei der us-finanzministerin die
klar stellte dass die Umstände heute
anders sein als bei der Finanzkrise 2008
damals wurden Investoren und Besitzer
großer Banken vom Staat gerettet seitdem
haben wir das finanzsystem-
wir wollen uns vor allem um die Einleger
und ihre Bedürfnisse kümmern
die SVB die zahlreiche Start-ups
finanzierte war nach Milliardenverlusten
beim wertpapierverkauf in massive
Schwierigkeiten geraten die Bank hatte
zur niedrigzinszeit hohe Beträge in
langfristige US-Staatsanleihen angelegt
nach den Zinserhöhungen schlitterten die
Kurse nach unten und die SVB in die
Krise
Banken gehen verschiedene Risiken ein
und haben unterschiedliche
Geschäftsmodelle das auch mal eine
scheitert ist normal wichtig ist dass
diese scheitern durch die
risikoinvestments verursacht wurde und
nicht durch die Unternehmen die ganz
alltägliche Transaktionen machten was
die SVB angeht würde ich schon gern
wissen wie die regulationsbehörden
umgegangen sind mit dem explosiven
Wachstum der Bank das auch auf riskanten
Investments beruhte
die Aufarbeitung wird wohl noch lange
dauern trotz weltweiter Kurseinbrüche
rechnen Experten bisher eher nicht mit
einer neuen Finanzkrise vergleichbar mit
Jena vor 15 Jahren
und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz auch noch mal mit
Wirtschaftsnachrichten Deutschland und
Brasilien wollen ihre Wirtschaft
Beziehungen vertiefen am zweiten Tag
seines Brasilien Besuchs hat
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck in bilo
Horizonte die deutsch-brasilianischen
Wirtschaftstage eröffnet Unternehmen bei
der ländervereinbarten eine engere
Zusammenarbeit vor allem bei
nachhaltiger Energie habe ich sagte
Brasilien sei schon jetzt bei
erneuerbaren Energien stark und habe
große Chancen für eine
Wasserstoffproduktion
mehrere deutsche Flughäfen waren heute
von Warnstreiks betroffen in Hamburg und
am Hauptstadtflughafen BER wurden alle
Starts gestrichen auch in Hannover und
Bremen hatte die Gewerkschaft Verdi zu
Warnstreiks aufgerufen Hintergrund sind
parallel laufende tarifkonflikte in
verschiedenen Branchen etwa im
öffentlichen Dienst
und noch zum Sport zum Skispringen da
wurde Selina Freitag heute in
Lillehammer zweite hinter der
norwegerinsel
Weltmeisterin Katharina Althaus kam
nicht aufs Podium
Schneefall machte das Springen der
Frauen in Lillehammer bei der zweiten
Station der Tour in Norwegen zu einer
echten Herausforderung Weltmeisterin
Katharina Althaus nach dem ersten
Durchgang nur neunte mit ihrem starken
zweiten Sprung landet sie am Ende
immerhin auf Frank 5 Berliner Freitag
trotzdem niedrigen Bedingungen mit
121,5 und 128 Metern springt sie auf
Platz 2 und landet damit nur 0,6 Punkte
hinter der Norwegerin
das war von uns vielleicht nach dem
Wetter geht es mit dem montagskino
weiter und um 05 meldet sich dann wohl
Schmiede mit unserem heute schnell
Update
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend mit 24 Grad war es heute in
Rheinfelden kaum kühler als auf den
Kanarischen Inseln mit 25 Grad so warm
bleibt es aber bei uns nicht denn diese
warmluftblase verabschiedet sich schon
morgen auswärts das die Florin bringt
deutlich tiefere Temperatur mit das
sehen Sie an der blauen Farbe jetzt am
Anfang der Nacht haben wir es noch mit
Gewittern besonders in Baden-Württemberg
zu tun sonst fällt häufig Regen bei
starkem bestürmischen Südwestwind die
Temperaturen sinken auf Werte zwischen
zehn und drei Grad und liegen morgen bei
7 Grad in Ostfriesland und 14 Grad im
Spreewald morgen Vormittag ziehen
Regenwolken der nachdem Südosten ab
zwischen Thüringen und der Uckermark
wird freundlich und von Nordwesten kommt
schon die nächste Kaltfront hinterher
die breitet sich im Laufe des
Nachmittags weiter nach Südosten aus da
sind auch einzelne Gewitter dabei und
Schnee Regenschauer dabei dreht der Wind
von südwestlichen immer mehr auf
nordwestliche Richtungen und es gibt
weitere starke Böden weitere Regen und
schneeregenschauer gibt es dann auch
noch am Mittwoch von Westen wird schon
freundlicher der Donnerstag wird dann
insgesamt ruhiger bei 6 bis 15 Grad und
am Freitag scheint dann häufig die Sonne
bei Temperaturen von bis zu 20 Grad und
damit wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen
Abend